how did you switch from atheism
to being a christian what happened
it was during covet and i actually i i
you know you when you're in the
conservative space there's so many
people who are christian many of them
fake christians just going to be honest
with you at least in the leadership
positions and so
i was someone who kind of considered
myself a fake christian a little bit
and you know i was saying that i was
kind of religious but wasn't really
doing anything so when kovet hit i was
home alone i decided to order the quran
and then order the bible to read both
and so i ended up reading the bible and
i read the four gospels and it's really
like with anything that when you get any
sort of type of information presented to
you
and you either have to make a choice you
either ignore the information you accept
it as truth or you think that it's false
and so what i did after i read it i said
okay i think that this is true and i'm
going to to change my life because of it
and i decided to to get baptized
that was about a year ago a year ago
like or a year and a couple months ago i
got baptized in hermosa beach california
by pastor jack kibbs and
it was a one of the greatest decisions i
ever made was to do that you know your
life gets harder doing that but it's
it's well worth it
so what changed
well it's
you know i think a lot of people still
expect that
christianity is supposed to make your
life better in some ways you know the
life that you're living now while you're
here on this earth in your physical body
that is supposed to make your life
better because now you believe in god
and he's going to come and he's going to
answer your prayers and he's going to
make it better but in a lot of ways your
life's get your life gets harder because
now essentially you're living by certain
tenets
from the bible from scripture
that are different than the way you were
living before and to live up to those
standards is actually more difficult and
so your life doesn't actually get easier
and you know being someone who believes
in something strongly that other people
actually don't really believe in and
being kind of in some ways against the
world the world hates you for what you
believe in uh it makes your life harder
you know especially if you're a strong
christian like i am and or my fiance is
or any of the other strong religious
people who really
get down to it people will hate you for
what you believe and they will hate you
for the values i mean they are hating
people who are pro-life right now that
you'll see i mean going and protesting
out of out at justice's houses and
screaming at them intimidating judges
breaking federal code i mean that's what
happens when you stand up for life and
when you stand up for things that are
biblically sound
so it gets tougher but the payoff i
believe is much better
i would say you're saved seems like a
pretty good payoff yeah exactly that's
that's that's
there's nothing better than that you
know if jesus if jesus died
for your sins on the cross and you read
the four gospels and you believe that
then you really have no other choice but
to give your life to him and so that's
what i did
wow so that was over covid interesting
yeah yeah
do you think there's a resurgence in
christianity and do you think part of
that is
because of
you know the chaos that we're seeing out
there
oh definitely a hundred percent
every all young people that you talk to
nowadays are incredibly nihilist
most of them think that there is no
purpose in life everything is
meaningless and they don't really want
to do anything they have no passion or
drive they move to some urban city and
again become an uber driver a girl on
only fans or they work for some big mega
corporation that's owned by a bigger
mega corporation and they there's no
passion there and so everyone feels
pretty down about their lives and so
they need some sort of meaning in their
lives and so really they choose either
leftism
and and marxism and the communism and
all these social justice stuff they
choose that or they choose christianity
and this is why i think christianity is
actually very tied to conservatism